la réserve de soap entre river sur le
bord du lac huron au nord de l'ontario
c'est ici que tamara malcom a trouvé
refuge
il y a huit ans pour mener le combat de
sa vie
[Musique]
et
c'est la cinquième fois seulement en
disant que les fils de tamar en ont le
droit de la visite est chez elle
la manitobaine a refait sa vie avec un
commerçant de la réserve un ami chanabé
comme elle quand ils reviennent chez
leur mère les enfants retrouvent leur
identité autochtone et aux êtres même
les repas en famille sont des cercles de
discussion on se parle pour atténuer les
tensions entre frères qui n'ont pas vécu
ensemble depuis plus de dix ans
depuis ce jour d'octobre 2007
lui qui avait sept ans à l'époque
revient de l'école avec des blessures à
la tête
tamara l'emmène à l'hôpital sur le champ
c'est là que tout bascule sommet entre
[Musique]
la police qui la soupçonne d'avoir
frappé son fils l'interrogent pendant
onze heures dès sa libération
la maman se précipite à l'hôpital mais
trop tard il est déjà parti pris en
charge par la protection de la jeunesse
au même moment des agents débarque chez
la mère de tamara et emmène ses deux
autres garçons dont le bébé de sept mois
sleep and coming back finalement
l'accusation de voies de fait contre
tamara est abandonnée si son conjoint de
l'époque qui est condamné pour avoir
frappé son garçon
[Musique]
après cette journée qui le marquera à
vie lit connaîtra une famille d'accueil
en huit ans
avec musulmane
tamara se séparent immédiatement de son
conjoint violent est temps de récupérer
ses trois garçons mais elle n'aura
aucune nouvelle d'eux pendant un an
déjà à l'époque comme bien des mères qui
perdent la garde et la trace de leurs
enfants
tamara se met à boire
[Musique]
des cérémonies traditionnelles comme le
smage une forme de purification qu'elle
fait ici avec ses enfants
l'aide à se relever depuis 2008 elle ne
boit plus ne fume plus et ne consomme
aucune drogue mais la souffrance de six
fils continuent de la hanter
l'adolescent dont nous devons protéger
l'identité avait presque cinq ans quand
un policier l'a arraché des bras de sa
grand mère
il n'a pas revu sa mère pendant quatre
ans à ostrow doute un jour l'enfant un
choc en voyant sa maman qu'il croit
morte à la télévision elle explique
qu'elle marche de winnipeg à ottawa pour
tenter de récupérer ses enfants
hayden se lit aussi convaincu que si les
enfants demeurent en foyer d'accueil
longtemps c'est pour des raisons
d'argent
la pollution
m